a 1.3 trillion dollar spending bill to
keep the government funded through
September is now in the hands of the
Senate the House passed the measure
earlier today President Trump must sign
it before midnight tomorrow to avoid
another partial shutdown chief
congressional correspondent and will is
live on Capitol Hill with the latest on
where things stand right now good
evening Mike Chris good evening there
were some complaints today about price
tag and process but now it is one hurdle
down one more to go and this vote the
yeas are 256 the nays are 167 a seeing a
Friday night deadline the house is sent
a 1.3 trillion dollar government funding
package to the Senate for consideration
after this pitch from the House Speaker
vote YES for our military vote yes for
the safety and the security of this
country vote yes the spending package
includes almost six hundred fifty five
billion dollars for national defense
nearly forty eight billion dollars for
homeland security 21 billion dollars for
infrastructure projects and almost 1.6
billion dollars for barriers and
technology on the border there was
plenty of support from Democrats since
it is a bipartisan compromise but the
House Democratic whip hammered the GOP
for voting on it before anyone had read
the more than 2200 page bill as I said
nobody's read that either
this is report language come to the well
if you've read this language in a
last-ditch effort the conservative
freedom caucus applied pressure from the
right appealing to President Trump to
stop the spending package put a good
builder from the president he'd support
that too I know he would so let's put
good legislation but let's not bring the
worst bill I've seen in my 10 years in
Congress to the floor the house the
White House swiftly shut down that
arguments is the president going to sign
the bill the answer is yes why because
it funds his priorities part of the
Senate Majority Leader's pitched for
support our components addressing
background checks and school safety this
bill will include two important
bipartisan common-sense measures to
address real issues facing the nation
the fix next bill and the stop school
as for when the Senate might send it to
the president that depends one person is
you know can can shut the place down if
they want to so it's really up to our
members bipartisan Senate leadership is
eager to vote tonight in fact they're
trying to get an agreement to vote later
this hour it is possible though one or
more senators may want to make a point
and burn some clock Chris Mike Emanuel
with the latest on Capitol Hill Mike
thank you